depuis une dizaine de jours ça s'est
stabilisé la semaine de relâche n'est
pas encore terminée que le premier
ministre a choisi d'y alidou nouveaux
assouplissements à compter de lundi
prochain les régions de la capitale
nationale de chaudière appalaches de
l'estrie de la mauricie et du centre du
québec passeront du rouge à l'orangé et
salle à manger des restaurants
rouvriront tout comme les salles de
spectacle et les salles d'entraînement
le couvre-feu sera repoussée de 20h à
21h30
si jamais il y avait une détérioration
on a un peu de marge de manoeuvre dans
les nouvelles hong kong mais orange
par contre pourquoi on laisse les autres
zones rouges parce qu'il ya pas de marge
de manoeuvre
de fait plus de 60 % des québécois soit
5,2 millions de personnes continueront
de se trouver en zone rouge
la grande région de montréal y compris
l'entièreté des laurentides de
lanaudière et de la montérégie demeurera
au palier d' alerte maximale
on peut prévoir l'autre c'est ce que les
experts prévoient c'est qu'on pourrait
surtout dans la grande région de
montréal voir une augmentation des
coptes des hospitalisations dans les
prochaines semaines que je devrais pas
vous interprétez aujourd'hui qu'on large
on assouplit avec un risque calculé
on peut pas se permettre la même chose
dans la région de montréal que au reste
du québec le québec se trouve donc
divisé en deux et les réactions sont à
l'avenant y est selon qu'on change de
couleur avoir plus de permissions ça va
faire du bien au moral ou qu'on reste au
rouge aux notes qui codent qu'on soit
+11 zone rouge puisque en plus aller
visiter d'autres régions d'autres encore
comme dans ce restaurant de la mauricie
ne savent pas s'ils doivent se réjouir
ou pas ça crée un peu d'incertitude
on y perd un peu par surprise on
s'attendait pas à voir une ouverture
ainsi potable
autre annonce de taille les sport
étudiant et toutes les autres activités
parascolaires pourront reprendre partout
sur le territoire du québec à compter du
15 mars
je pense avoir fait du bien aux jeunes
changement aussi pour les lieux de culte
qui pourront accueillir jusqu'à 100
personnes en zone orange le premier
ministre répète pour la énième fois
depuis le début de la pandémie que
l'espoir est à nos portes
appuyant cette fois ci sa promesse sur
la campagne de vaccination massive
le gouvernement se porte d'ailleurs à la
défense du vaccin d'astrazeneca
le ministre de la santé tout comme le
directeur national de santé publique
affirment tous deux qu'ils
n'hésiteraient pas un instant à le
recevoir
si on leur offrait ici hugo lavallée
radio canada québec